g fuel g fuel is running a big contest
log 10 grand lucky son of a gun
winners will win the opportunity of a
lifetime
if i may say so myself one year supply
of g-fuel say it with me one year
supply of g-fuel just imagine what you
can do with that
that's 12 tubs of g-fuel baby one
pewdiepie g-fuel starter kit my god
if you haven't signed up for this yet
boy i got bad news for you
you're a dummy ball club log
one collector's edition g fuel pin
okay all right my god
a g-fuel collector's pin guys do you
understand
do you understand and this is not just
it the 20 runner-up
will receive a g-fuel starter kit
or and a collector's g fuel pin
listen up guys link it's in description
you know what to do
let's freaking get this bread that's
right everyone i just throw it out there
as such a good person
i know it's photoshop time baby
so many people have been literally
begging me to do another photoshop video
and i always say no that's a terrible
idea
but hey here we are everyone photoshop
hey phyllis can you photoshop
something please bye there has been a
couple things
that have been bothering me that i
haven't seen anyone do
properly so i guess i will have to do
this
number one will smith genie looks like
trash
how can we make it better everyone hates
this genie
you know i'm not supposed to give my
opinion but i think it's kind of hot
this really looks like a bad just
face slapped on
like it just looks terrible you could
literally add any face on top of this so
easily
i think i think what gives it away
it's honestly this line here i don't
know if this is intentional but this
it's almost like you can it's almost
like you can see like
where they cut his face onto this 3d
model or however they did it i don't
know
or maybe that's just like a small
mistake is it in the other shots
i guess this is the shape of his face
but i think
i'm just curious
10 out of 10 baby
oh that's great
it's kind of purpley decrease the noise
fix the light thing there we go
starting to look decent fix his limp
really quick
i don't know why i did this it's not
funny there's nothing to it i just
wanted to see if i could do it better
which i clearly can't because before it
is all [ __ ]
there you go everyone new and improved
now for the final detail
we go now that's an l i didn't that i
would personally watch
and it's family friendly thanks to me
you're welcome disney
i'll be waiting for my paycheck what
will be the worst
face to have on this body
should make me laugh oh my god
oh god
marcia i'm sorry okay
i just sometimes i get questions that i
know i don't want the answer
for but i need to see it i need to
witness it
okay this is straight up nightmare fuel
it's a masterpiece honestly
it doesn't even look bad
[Laughter]
oh i just realized uh the
here's the lips and then the beard is
down here
but we cannot have that okay i actually
like it
marzia confirmed for the next disney
film
looks like they fired will smith and
went with what
they oh and went with what
should have been their first option for
the genie
there we go oh look everyone going who
is that
who who's that felix
a lot of people have been talking about
how will smith looks like
blue shrek so i'm curious how
exactly does blue shrek
actually look like you know every single
day i just sit here and i use the pen
tool
to crop myself out
you know i'd like to think at least you
know i'm getting better at photoshop for
doing these god awful thumbnails every
day
when in reality
i'm just god at using the pen tool
that's all it's ever done for me first
of all we need to put
him in the right location to really
immerse ourselves
into the landscape jazz
that looks terrible
you know i can work with it is there a
better ver
yeah okay here we go okay i like this
one
i think this is the keeper now of course
we're gonna have to turn them green
which is probably one of the most
difficult things
you could ever possibly do all right
we're done
[Laughter]
what is the color of shrek though like
is he that's a
disgusting yellow isn't it now of course
the most
iconic part of strength the ears
everyone
it actually works that's the weirdest
part
did you guys know that will smith was
actually gonna play
shrek but he said no
because he was going to play in wild
west instead
crazy i know
legit legit like i don't think that
needs more work
i mean i guess i guess i should cover up
this but still
that's it i see
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah sun
sun look at that look at that ears
look at those i want to suck on that
all right you can judge me all you want
everyone has wanted to suck
on shrek's ears goddammit i just
realized
his left one is bigger than the right
one that's just ridiculous we cannot
have that
that's more like it i guess i guess we
have to get rid of his
hat thing hair it's hair felix oh okay
sorry should be simple delete
and then we'll fill in we'll fill in the
blank with a little
i mean it doesn't look bad there you go
there you go fixed your thing
why am i wasting time doing this
why just suffer i just want to see it
through
you know i can't feel my leg
i just want to see it through i told you
guys
when i get an idea even if it's not
good i wanna see it
oh
god all right wait i'm i'm doing all
right so
you guys think this is shrek's vest
i don't but it's the clothes that i can
find okay
why am i laughing it's not even funny
okay
oh yeah it only covers like part of his
body hey look we added a texture
look at that voice
[Music]
bam it looks just like the real
oh why am i doing this
stop well hey guys it's trick here
that's not the shrek voice idiot hi guys
that made drag
what's the shrek what's a shrek voice an
ogre
i'm a no okay i don't do impressions i
do photoshop
please okay is there any good reason to
do this
no is there any good reason to do
anything in life no
so there you have it kids oh my god
another masterpiece thank you very much
uh i think it's time we let this one go
though actually let me see before and
after because i'm curious what i've done
before
see they both look [ __ ] oh god they both
look [ __ ] like
honestly they both look so bad
they're both so bad oh
god disney needs to hire me come on
i mean don't they're just gonna fire me
but anyway
mission accomplished i think so
okay as you may or may not know dog
bowser
is the new ceo of nintendo america
dog bowser new ceo of nintendo america
very you know with a name like that you
know clearly people want to see the
transformation right
of bowser turning into actual bowser
it's not like he's probably heard this
joke a million times before i mean look
at people die
people 10 days and it's like no
we want a proper one i mean that i i'll
i'll hand it to you the the bounce set
ones are pretty good
but i want an actual bouncer because
he's not bow set god damn it
oh hell oh yes oh the quality
the quality never leave high
quality photos on the internet just
don't do it
it ain't worth it oh my god yes
dog first of all if you're listening
watching and listening i'm sorry
okay i don't know what is about to
happen
but where do i begin this is like
plastic surgery
because i'm thinking like what part of
his skin can i take
and actually use because i'm thinking i
can use his cheeks to make these bit
oh my god
it makes me so uncomfortable okay
great let's do the chin my god
i mean i could just steal from the same
layer
reshape it slightly
oh god
that is a butt chin if i've ever seen
one
god damn god
damn boy
dog i'm sorry i'm doing this out of
necessity
just just understand
his nostril is like perfect shape oh
god oh god oh god
oh god what is that try to do is
nostrils
every day we stray further away from god
oh god
no what i think i want to like keep the
essence of the smile
and not do like pointy teeth or anything
well so far all i've accomplished is
basically
put a bunch of tumor on this poor man's
face but uh yeah no it's pretty good
trying to hold it in my hand but it
falls apart
[Music]
ah i wanna cry it makes me so
uncomfortable
oh my god oh
bowser
bowser y ah
oh my god
the more i look the more i'm like oh god
what have i done 10 out of
10. say it with me 10 out of 10.
this is what i'm talking about huh
picasso picasso would have
loved this let's look at the original
just so we get a sense of contrast oh
god
[Laughter]
[Music]
kawaii this name
please no more well ask and you shall
receive thank you guys for watching
another photoshop video
if you enjoyed and want more smash like
speaking of fantastic artworks
check out the latest merch the hottest
merch if you're an absolute mad lad only
of course limited time only